gwen stefani celebrates blake shelton on
father's day by posting a clip of her
hubby playing with her son
the no doubt singer dedicated a touching
tribute to blake on instagram wrestling
on the ground with her eight-year-old
son apollo in the caption she wrote
grateful for you every day blake shelton
you feel more grateful than ever i mean
truly we do gwen who has been married to
blake since 2021 posted a series of pics
of her man with her boys looking happier
than ever
[Music]
gwen also shared how she's thankful for
the country crooner through the good and
bad writing god really gave me you for
the ups and downs it's something blake
told et drew him to gwen after he split
from his ex miranda lambert and gwen
called it quits with her ex gavin
rosdale with whom she shares three sons
kingston zuma and apollo both of our
lives have basically
fallen completely apart
and uh and little did we know it
happened to both of us at the same time
somewhere in in that you know that
time of
of just you know darkness was this
ended up being the greatest moment of my
life but get this blake's 46th birthday
fell on the same weekend as father's day
so naturally gwen kept the celebration
post coming posting a throwback clip of
the pair performing together
[Music]
[Music]
and a sweet moment of gwen surprising
blake on stage with a cake
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the love fest continues off stage
for the couple check out mr and mrs
shelton earlier this month stepping out
for a glam date night gwen turning heads
in an ombre gown next to her handsome
hubby i think somebody that can make you
laugh constantly is very sexy and
somebody that is
let's see humble
kind down to earth
selfless talented on the top of their
game
should i keep going and soon gwen will
reunite with blake as a coach on the
voice
fittingly she announced the big news
with the performance
and when e.t spoke with gwen last year
she made it clear any chance to work
with her man is a big yes i want to do
everything with him every day so anytime
we can be together perform write songs
hang out watch tv whatever it is i'm all
about blake
[Music]
you